hey everybody welcome to the podcast my
guest today is dr andrew huberman andrew
is a neuroscientist he's a neurobiology
professor at stanford medical school
a mcknight foundation and pew foundation
fellow and the founder of hubermann lab
where he's involved in all kinds of
really amazing breakthrough research on
brain function brain plasticity and
brain regeneration
his work has been published in top
journals like nature he's been featured
in publications like time scientific
american the bbc
and he's here today to discuss the brain
to discuss growth mindset how to focus
how to navigate these stressful times
and many other subjects it's an
incredible conversation i think you guys
are going to enjoy it i appreciate you
watching make sure to hit that subscribe
button and without further ado this is
me and dr andrew huberman
[Music]
first of all thanks for doing this i
appreciate you coming out yeah my
pleasure long time coming i'm glad we're
doing it in person and
remotely
um and i think what i want to do is
start with your uh your your origin
story because you're very it's your path
is very unlikely your your path to
becoming a scientist and i think it
actually also kind of contextualizes
some of the things that i want to talk
about with you today
so maybe start there sure so um on the
one hand
you know maybe i was fated to become a
scientist
um i guess the the two things that are
relevant there are i always loved
animals and i've always been obsessed
with animal behavior i just could watch
cousteau shows growing up you know
underwater life or
animals hunting animals doing anything
is just so fascinating to me because i'm
i think even at a really young age i've
always just been intrigued in sort of
what drives different animals to behave
in the way they do and how body form
matches to i don't know what it was but
brains and how that all works so i've
always been obsessed with animals um and
then my dad's a scientist so
he's a physicist i was really early in
chaos theory and so growing up
um in our home you know we had
scientists over for dinner and graduate
students would come over for barbecues
and things like that is he a stanford
professor uh he he was at stanford he
was mostly at xerox park which is kind
of famous if you read the steve jobs
book is for the yeah the development of
the gui interface the graphic user
interface and sort of early days of the
computer so he had a lab there and he
had a lab in applied physics at stanford
and something called symbolic systems
which is a stanford degree in kind of
ecology and computation that kind of
thing so i grew up in this family where
um science was very prominent and
we had lots of discussions in our home
that i would overhear and i didn't
understand about physics and uh we'd
spend summers at the aspen center for
physics uh which was like good times
yeah so
you know and we were and to be clear you
know you hear the word aspen you know we
were a middle class family um but they
have this aspen center for physics so
the feynman you know richard feynman was
there murray gilman like all these
luminaries of physics peter kaus
and my dad was really good at telling me
the stories about these guys and then
i'd always want to meet them it was
mostly guys back then there weren't many
women in physics so
i you know i was kind of immersed in
science from a young age but
right about age
13
my parents split up and he moved
overseas he moved to denmark
and my mom was really struggling with
the breakup and
i wasn't in contact with him anymore so
i had this really unusual childhood
where you know we didn't talk about
sports we talked about science and i had
this close relationship with science and
the people around science but then all
of a sudden the structure around family
like instead of dinners together every
night it was just like me and my mom
and i was an adolescent i was hitting
puberty so you know
there was bound to be some shifts in my
world landscape and internal landscape
anyway
but basically what happened was i
stopped really paying attention to
school and i got really heavily into
skateboarding and kind of punk rock
music and i found
my pack or my community through like
a packing community of kids that also
just were kind of parentless so this was
like late 80s early 90s yeah and so at a
pretty young age i started taking the i
grew up in palo alto i was actually born
at stanford hospital um and started
taking the 7f bus up to san francisco
and hanging around embarcadero
for the skateboarders out there the
lizards this is the the now um famous uh
emb crowd so this was the the birth of a
huge movement of skateboarders that
became professionals like so you'd see
the young danny way would come through
town and you had um rob dyrdick i
remember when he came through and so so
all these names that eventually became
popular during the kind of x games era
in the um
but at that time it was really
underground and so is this pack of maybe
a hundred guys
and it was run like a little city and it
was chaos it was like there was fights
and there was drinking and there was um
lawlessness there was also a lot of
amazing skateboarding yeah and a lot of
amazing people and there were some older
guys um
like one in particular uh a very famous
skateboarder is this kid mike carol his
older brother was kind of like the older
brother to everybody kind of kept us all
in check so it had its own
unique organization and it's actually
interesting because the same thing was
happening at that time in washington
square park in new york and in love park
in philadelphia there were all these
like communities of kids that were
basically perilous and so in that time i
saw some interesting things first of all
i learned what it was to be parentless
growing up in palo alto it was like
soccer games and ayso and you know swim
swim club and all of a sudden i realized
you know i don't have to be home at any
particular time or
you know
none of these kids are going to school
and so we all it was a kind of big group
of truants and um
it was interesting because it gave me a
perspective that i had never had in palo
alto and i was drifting further and
further away from any kind of academic
rigor right i think i would go to school
every once in a while what's mom doing
does she have any idea that you're going
up to the city every day so she was
totally checked out
you know i think she was just devastated
by a bunch of things that were happening
and um she lapsed into a pretty serious
depression and then
in that community what was interesting
is i started seeing that you know some
guys were clearly fated to becoming
professional skateboarders they were
really good at it i i just want to say
for full disclosure i was not
particularly good i kept getting injured
um i just i was not fated to be
you know exceptional or very good at it
but i love the camaraderie and i love
the community but i also noticed that
you know some people were drinking all
day and other people got into hard drugs
and people started to you know some of
the the dysfunction really started to
show the fracture yeah the fracture yeah
exactly and so um
and i started seeing that a lot a lot
more violence you know people started
getting their girlfriends pregnant they
didn't have money to support those kids
you know it started becoming apparent to
me that there was a lot of dysfunction
as well as a lot of incredible people in
that community
and so
about that time i got a girlfriend um
and the other thing was i got removed
from high school so i went to kind of
the famed slash infamous high school in
palo alto gun high school oh you went to
ghana i went to gun which is famous
because it's
the one of the most academically
rigorous schools in the
you know country maybe the planet people
moved to the area just to send their
kids there but it also has this um very
complicated reputation as the high
suicide rate of any school in the
country the new york times is written
about this
so
you know i would come to school every
once in a while but i could tell you far
more about the curbs in the front of the
gun high school parking lot than i could
about anything that i learned yeah so
when they say they rem you you were
removed i mean you got you were expelled
uh no i basically they just said you
need to either start coming to school or
you know or you're done so i got shifted
to another high school
and that was the same story it just was
it was a mess it just fell apart and so
at one point um
i was brought in a kind of vague
recollection of this but i was brought
in to have a discussion with a school
counselor
and um i don't think i've ever told this
story before and there was someone
sitting in the corner
this guy was sitting in the corner and
he didn't introduce himself and pretty
soon i realized i was like i think
they're gonna take me away like i
started realize because they realized my
mom wasn't really able to control me
wasn't really in a place to support me
um
at that time and so and that's what they
did they took me away they took me to a
place up the peninsula which was not a
jail and it wasn't a hospital it was
just sort of a place where they put kids
that were like some kind of uv wear hat
warehousing situation yeah a lot of
psychologists a lot of um a lot of locks
on doors a lot of a lot of kids that um
there were 12 of us in there at any one
time
um it was locked down
and the first night there i remember i
had a roommate who um was like really
into cutting on himself that kind of
thing and he told me he he's like look
if you just do what they say here you'll
be out of here in like a month uh-huh
and if you don't you're gonna be here a
very long time and i remember being
pretty frightened for the first time
um
and
at that point i was like oh my goodness
like this is bad you know like this is
bad i'm a long so hard for me to imagine
i know i know just given you know who
you are and what you do i know and you
know and it was literally like the kind
of one phone call a day kind of thing so
actually i called i was skateboarding
for a company in san francisco i think
they put me on out of sympathy and i
called this guy up and i said um look
i've you know they locked me up i don't
know what to do can you help me and he
and i'll never forget i want to say his
name he goes you're the most normal guy
i know
well he's like least likely of that
crowd exactly what happened so in any
event i was permitted to go back to
school eventually um provided that i
went to therapy and so i started going
to weekly therapy which in the early 90s
was kind of a weird thing you wouldn't
admit it to your friends but sweet
skateboard around stanford campus i was
doing my thing and then twice a week i
would go in and see this this therapist
he's a remarkable guy because um a he
had deep training in the mind right and
we started talking about what was going
on and and he really picked up on the
fact that there was essentially no
structure no home life for me but that i
had a strong drive and i was really
interested in learning i mean i was i
was i was enthusiastic and motivated
enough to you know skateboard as hard as
i could even though i wasn't going to go
anywhere with it
so at that point and the fact that i had
a girlfriend
i started
looking for something that i could do
and um
i started at one point i thought i
joined the fire service because it
seemed like the camaraderie was good at
that point i started strengthening my
body a bit because i didn't want to keep
getting hurt so i started running i
started lifting weights a football coach
at gun
actually um turned me on to fitness it's
actually an interesting guy he wrote the
script for that movie mr mom do you
remember that oh my god yeah um because
his wife bet him he couldn't do what
what she could do which was stay home
with the kids and he was this big strong
football coach and so he made her bet
and they and he lost and so he wrote
that script michael keaton played the
you know so he taught me he was like
look you know you can't even do a
pull-up you need to start doing your
pull-ups and you start running you know
and he said the fire service might be
good for you so so i was spinning out
but there were people that were willing
to kind of you know point me in the
right direction so what ended up
happening was my high school girlfriend
went off to college
and i didn't you know i didn't know what
i was going to do so i actually went and
i lived in the parking lot outside her
dormitory i just want to be near her she
was my family at that at that point like
college locally or she was at uc santa
barbara so you just you drove down and i
just drove down i just camped out in the
parking lot and
and and i was starting to get into some
martial arts and thai boxing then so i
think i was teaching some thai boxing
self-defense stuff on campus and doing
this kind of thing
and by the end of that year i realized
that i should probably apply to college
so i applied to ucsb
and somehow i got in lord knows how i
got in i did because i did eventually
graduate high school barely
um got in and then after a year i just
completely flailed it you know i wasn't
going to class i was getting into fights
a lot of that kind of um
kind of mischief and kind of wildness
was still in me
and what ended up happening was
um i got into a physical altercation on
july 4th 1994 with like a bunch of guys
and at the end of that i walked back to
the place i was staying
and of course i wasn't paying rent
because i learned in those years like
you can just squat in an empty house so
you know it's isla vista california you
know so i was really running wild and
went back and just i realized i was like
this picture is really bad you know at
some point this isn't going to be like a
kid who had some problems this is going
to be
truly not cute anymore it's not cute no
one's going to make excuses about your
upbringing or the lack of parenting it
just becomes
you just you're going to end up being a
ward of the state i mean you were it
sounds like you were you're almost of a
feral animal totally
actually and uh i have some close
friends that that um that's how they
they refer to me really farrell and it's
funny even to this day i mean uh i'll
get to where this eventually took me but
even to this day when i go into a home
where it's clearly like a loving home
where there's kids are happy and there's
good food and it's warm and cozy i i
always feel this thing like wow like
amazing like i i sort of want to be
adopted by them immediately but you know
i'm 45 years old so that's not
appropriate at this point it's so
interesting
i keep thinking about
david epstein's book range did you read
this book which is basically uh
this thesis that some of the most
successful people
are not you know we we suspect that you
know the great talents of of the world
across all disciplines are the people
who discover their passion at an early
age and practice it voraciously for many
many many years but in fact
it's people more like yourself who've
dabbled in all different kinds of things
who end up being ultimately
you know the most proficient at their
selected skill set and when i look at
your experience i see trauma i see
adventure i see you know all these
obstacles that you've had to face and
overcome and manage on your own
essentially right and all of those
really inform perfectly the things that
you're interested in and what you
explore today in your lab
yeah it really did you know i think that
um i'm so grateful for those years i
wouldn't wish them on any kid because i
think having a secure loving environment
at home is so key and you know i should
say about a third of the kids that i
grew up with in that environment that
whole skateboarding punk rock culture
about a third have gone on to found
companies or professional skateboarders
about a third just kind of drifted off
and about a third are dead or
incarcerated yeah you know a huge number
and
so there's real value in having a
support system uh that's clear but it
exposed me to all these things like
addiction schizophrenia rage like all
these incredible elements like i was
never really into drinking in drugs i
could drink or not drink it this was i
wasn't drawn to it but other people they
took one sip and i was like that was
their thing right it was like the magic
elixir for them and so i you know i was
observing what was happening and then
after that you know that july 4th 94
incident was
i realized this is it you know it's now
or never it really was one of those
moments you know you hear about those
moments but it was
me realizing i'm living in this squat
well i've got a pet ferret my
girlfriend's gone she broke up with me
she was smart enough to break up with me
you know um i'm getting in fights i'm
working at a bagel shop i barely make
ends meet and at that point i just made
the decision i just said okay
look i'm i'm not gonna be a professional
athlete i think i'm
pretty good at memorizing things i think
i have an interest in people
i'm going to just
decide i just decided to do school i
decided that was that was the track so
like some people picked the military
because it's like if you you know what
to expect at least in terms of the the
you know the passages that you're going
to go through and for me that was school
and so i hadn't decided to get back in
school i moved into a studio apartment
by myself i quit partying completely i
didn't go to parties i got
really serious about fitness so i just
started running and lifting weights
and i studied you went like henry
rollins style i did yeah i did it's a
lot of self-awareness you know i mean
people go into the military because on
some level i mean some people do because
there there's some yearning for for
having that structure imposed upon their
lives but you
you constructed that
that kind of um structure for yourself
yeah i think i was really afraid
i think i was like you know and i and
these days you know because my lab
studies fear and i get into this whole
thing around mindsets people always ask
me like is it better to do something
from a place of love or fear like
depends and at that point fear was the
best motivator for me
and
i just basically worked like crazy and
and it's interesting because i didn't
have a mentor or someone to bring me to
that but once i started doing that you
know there was one professor in
particular who took note he was like oh
you know you seemed really interested in
this stuff and i was like yeah because
he was teaching me about depression
schizophrenia neurochemicals i was
totally turned on by the world of
neuroscience it wasn't even called
neuroscience back then but this one guy
harry carlisle he was teaching me about
thermal regulation and how the brain
works and how receptors in the skin
relate to perceptions in the mind
and and he also had a deep sensitivity
to mental disease
and i'd seen a lot of that you know i'd
seen
a lot of depression and anxiety in my
own family i'd had a friend
commit suicide another friend becomes
schizophrenic i think he's still walking
the mission district of san francisco
now
um seen some friends become addicts and
so here was some someone explaining that
there's actually an underlying basis for
this
and i just poured myself into is that
the same guy who uh who you know would
smoke underneath the the vacuum hood and
stuff like that like a bit of an
iconoclast yeah he was amazing so he was
a favorite teacher of many students but
if you could get into his lab
then you were kind of
one of the chosen ones i guess like the
perfect mentor at the perfect time for
you yeah so he used to drink coffee in
lab which you're not supposed to do he
used to smoke cigarettes in lab and in
the fume hood and they used to come and
yell at him and he would do it anyway um
and i thought you know this guy's he
doesn't even know what it is but he's
punk rocker he doesn't even know and so
you know he gave me an opportunity to
work in his lab and then at some point
he told me if you go to graduate school
they'll actually pay you to do science
and what ended up happening at that
point was i hit a brick wall because i
was i had a lot of resentment toward my
dad
i felt you know here's my dad he was a
scientist he had you know left us all
this kind of thing
and i realized if i didn't do this if i
didn't take this opportunity i it was
gonna be the most foolish thing ever you
know what am i gonna do spite my
you know
my parents be you know i was 20 years
old at that point so i just made the
decision i'm gonna be get a phd and
become a professor i'm gonna get tenure
and be like this guy you know this guy
who has looked like he had a pretty good
life to me
and so that's pretty much how i spent
the you know the last 25 years of my
life is um doing experiments it worked
out it worked out
a lot of work i mean i didn't have the
power of concentration i hadn't read all
the good books that gun high school
students read growing up i had to
learn how to speak properly i learned
how to learn how to think properly and
really learn how to
commit to something that was very linear
and at times was very painful and and i
went to some pretty extreme things i um
you know i actually used to
set a timer
uh and i wouldn't allow myself to get
out of the chair until i was the timer
went off right so and i would experience
extreme agitation but over time i got
pretty good and now i can do long stints
of work
without any breaks and um
yeah it worked out it developed that uh
that neural plasticity in your favor
ultimately you were always a reader
though right i loved books so i would
you know um i would hide in the tower
books section uh in the evenings and i
would read everything about fitness
psychology
anything i could i've always devoured
information my favorite book when i was
a kid was the encyclopedia or the
guinness book of worlds records so i
would like when i was a little kid i'd
walk around the aspen center for physics
and i would tell anyone i didn't even
ask them if they want to hear about like
the what's the world's smallest
eutherian mammal you know i would like
you could tell you all these facts that
were kind of meaningless at the time but
um i've always been fascinated by the
inventory of different animals on the
planet and their different behaviors and
so
yeah voracious reader and still now
yeah i love i love information well as a
neuroscientist i mean you're you're
you're your own patient i mean the fact
that you were able to you know turn your
life around in such a dramatic fashion
and do it essentially through sheer will
and you know setting up practices that
would fuel you you in that right
direction and then being available when
those mentors showed up from the from
the you know the early therapist sounds
like that guy almost saved your life he
absolutely saved my life he gave me the
book um wherever you go there you are
the john kobatson book and he said no
pressure but if you can develop a
mindfulness practice where you can sit
still for like 10 minutes a day it'll
serve you very well so i started doing
that like
he could have told me a hang out of a
window by my hand because i would have
done it i think there was a there was a
self-preservation
thing was kicking in for me
so i got very interested in mindfulness
meditation he also it was i think quite
smart in saying look there's a whole
world of psychedelic drugs that are
powerful in influencing the mind he said
if you're gonna explore those
wait until your brain has already
developed which i think is a
controversial statement in and of itself
um he so he actively discouraged me
to go down that path
um which i think was the right thing
given i was a minor you know and
nowadays there's all this discussion now
about psychedelics and their power and i
think they are very interesting
compounds but he really steered me
towards behavioral practices like what
could i do each day from waking up to
going to sleep
that would serve my mental health and my
productivity well right yeah i owe him a
tremendous amount and especially because
he wasn't just in the psychoanalytic
theory he also was like cognitive
behavioral he understood the power of
practices not just discussing issues
he had to begin a meditation practice at
that age in the mid-90s
that's pretty radical yeah i felt it was
funny because um
i thought if i didn't sit in the lotus
position
like i wasn't doing it properly you know
back then there was all this stuff
around it was very mystical and in my
family because my dad's very
conservative and my mom is a little bit
more of a free spirit
i was taught that anything that related
to hippie culture was doomed to fail and
cause problems and that anything that
was related to like conservative culture
was fated to advance the progress of
humanity right it turned out neither one
was true of course
um so i but i needed people to push me
in those directions lift weights run
meditate do your schoolwork do your
homework and so i think i you know now i
have a good relationship with my parents
but i think i had to go out into the
world and find those um you know sort of
paternal and maternal figures
because they weren't in my home i needed
do you find those do you look back on
your upbringing with gratitude like how
do you reflect on that experience and
how it informs you know how you think
about what you do now yeah i i'm
immensely grateful for it because
you know where i'm at today is you know
my lab works on a number of issues
related you know sort of hardcore
neurobiology of regenerating the brain
you know trying to fix
basically cure blindness and repair
visual systems but also things related
to you know fear courage mindset stress
anxiety trauma etc
and
the early seed of seeing how science is
done definitely gave me an advantage i
won't lie you know i seeing how
scientists interact and behave and
understanding that they are just people
because a lot of what was discussed in
my home was about the people not just
the science they do
um that really gave me an advantage
and then seeing all that that
dysfunction and realizing that the human
animal is amazing at making plans at
modifying its brain if it wants to but
the human brain and the human animal are
also
dreadfully bad
at doing what's best for us right
because of this what i think it comes
down to is the fact that our reward
systems are not designed for things that
are just good for us they're designed
for things that optimize the progression
of our species but they're also they
will grab onto and ratchet into any
behavior that makes us feel good and so
the human brain is really
not optimized for making best choices
right and so uh those years of seeing
all that testified yeah it's um
and and it's a i wouldn't trade those
years for anything and i still have
great friends in that community i mean i
think
um
you know any had i joined a different
community i would have found the right
people as well
but to be with a you know a huge pack of
feral kids at that age
and to see the function and dysfunction
and and also it was wild it was a lot of
fun i can imagine it was a lot of fun
yeah that's a whole set of stories you
see that movie mid 90s
mid 90s and the movie kids the larry
movie when i saw that movie first of all
i had a lot of friends that were in that
movie because he used actual
skateboarding kids yeah i actually knew
a couple of those kids um
and
you know
it's a movie but there were a lot of
things about that movie they were very
active yeah yeah and when i saw that
movie i was like yeah that's like right
pretty much a day in the life in
washington square park and you know i
mean it was a little extreme on some on
some end but you didn't know where
you're going to end up each night that
was a unique experience you know so
yeah and mid 90s was really good i think
it captured the essence of what it is to
be a kid that's just looking for some
some group of people to to join and
skateboarding is a unique sport because
you get young kids and grown men
and now women and girls do it as well it
didn't happen so much then but now there
are a lot of great awesome skateboarders
that are
female but they're all hanging out
together you wouldn't find that in
soccer you're not gonna get little kids
playing with grown men so you get
exposed to a lot
because everyone's at develop different
developmental stages but yeah it was an
amazing thing i wouldn't change it for
anything cool yeah well let's uh let's
segue into talking about the brain
and maybe we could start with you know
how you think about the brain
specifically like what is the brain what
does it do what does it not do you know
it helps us survive it's our portal into
trying to make sense of the world like
what's the starting point in the
discussion around the brain
yeah so
the brain and nervous system um which so
it's like brain spinal cord connections
with the body and back again i don't
distinguish between brain and mind i
think that's like a 80s discussion
or earlier and i think it it would take
us down the wrong track so brain or mind
to me is interchangeable
um mind body is kind of interchangeable
because
the brain is connected to the body and
the body's connected to the brain right
if i you know pinprick my hand and it
hurts my brain registers it where it
happens it's kind of an irrelevant
discussion now i think we really need to
just appreciate that the nervous system
is designed to orchestrate all the
processes in the body not just thinking
and not just behavior and really can be
divided into five things so
there's sensation
and sensation is really bound or
restricted by the receptors in the body
so
receptors in the eye that perceive
photons light energy
receptors in the skin that perceive
pressure you know touch receptors
smell taste hearing etc
and the interesting thing about
sensation and the fact that the nervous
system needs to pay attention to
sensation is it's non-negotiable
the nervous system of humans is designed
to extract physical phenomenon from the
universe that are non-negotiable photons
of light i can't see in the infrared
with my eyes and i can't see ultraviolet
light with my eyes and i can't perceive
that
because i don't have the receptors for
it
so
you know other animals can perceive some
of those things but that leads us to the
next thing which is perception which is
which sensations are you paying
attention to so all the time you're
sensing things like right now your feet
are sensing the contact with your shoes
but you're not thinking about it until i
say that and then you shift your
perception right so perception is like
the spotlight so the brain wants to
constantly bring in sensation it's
non-negotiable what's coming in it's
just depending on your environment
perception is negotiable you can control
that because i just said shoes and you
thought about your feet and there you
are
then there are feelings which
can be a little bit nebulous but
feelings are a link between our emotion
and
it generally invokes the body sensations
in the body and concepts in the mind of
what those sensations are about that's
really what emotions are animals
definitely experience them i'm kind of
appalled to think that 10 years ago
people like do animals have emotions of
course they have emotions right because
those are bodily sensations merged with
some perception so of course they do
and then there's thoughts and thoughts
are interesting because thoughts happen
spontaneously think about like a web
browser that's constantly giving you
pop-ups
but thoughts can also be deliberate so
you and i can decide right now that
we're going to think about a plan for
something or we're going to think about
what's going on in the world so thoughts
happen spontaneously and they can be
deliberate and then the final thing is
behaviors and actions so the nervous
system is responsible for sensation
perception feelings thoughts and
behaviors
and what's interesting
we start to think about that as you're
like okay that's a lot
but what is the nervous system really
trying to accomplish like on any given
day or at any moment what's it trying to
accomplish and it's really trying to
accomplish one thing which is to take
perceptions of the outside world
and merge those with perceptions of the
inside world what we call interoception
and to link those
in a way that's
operating on our environment in the
appropriate way so what do i mean by
that so if i'm feeling anxious and i'm
in a very calm environment i'm going to
perceive that rapid heart rate and kind
of feeling of agitation in my body as
inappropriate for the moment
right and my goal then as a as an
organism is to adjust my my level of
what they call autonomic arousals or
alertness down
if i'm in a at a great party or i'm at a
wedding or it's a celebration or i'm at
a protest or you know um
then i might feel that
my level of alertness is appropriate for
my environment so the nervous system is
in this constant dynamic
interaction with the outside world and
trying to figure that out
one way that this can be kind of
conceptualized is there's an emerging
idea that's kind of interesting about
impatience
so we've all had the feeling of being
impatient some people are far more
patient than others but if you've ever
been in line at the store
and you feel like something's going very
slowly you know the person in front of
you is taking a long time they're doing
some returns you're getting kind of
impatient maybe you're breathing in a
mask and you're like oh like you're you
know
what's the idea is that if you're
getting a certain frequency of pulses
from your body and if those pulses are
coming in quickly like you're perceiving
your yourself that enteroception quickly
it's like pulse pulse pulse pulse you're
going to be more geared towards your
internal representation and then you're
seeing what's going on in the outside
world and it seems like it's going very
slowly
but there are other times when you're in
line at the store someone's getting some
returns and you're texting on your phone
you've had a great day you've had a
great run your family's in great shape
and you're fine why well the frequency
of those pulses that interoception is
matched pretty well to your outside
environment and so impatience is really
when you're in internal sort of
metronome
is not matched well to the external
environment
there are other times when you're
feeling like your internal metronome is
tick tick tick and you've got a million
things coming at you through email or
text you've got a bunch of things and
you're feeling overwhelmed and tired
well in either case there's nothing
right or wrong it's just
your body and your brain are trying to
say what's going on in the outside world
and how well matched am i to it right so
if you think about some of the the sort
of core practices of mindfulness and
self-regulation of like focusing on
breathing or focusing on on you know
state of mind a lot of that is trying to
bring more awareness to your internal
state
but
what our brain is normally doing when
our eyes are open and we're interacting
in the world is we're constantly trying
to update our internal state to match
external demands of the world and this
harkens back to a you know like a really
early design of all nervous systems
which is how do you take an organism
that needs certain things food water
mates reproduction shelter how do you
move that organism how do you create a
system that will do that in best
relation to the environment
and so what mother nature has done is
designed a syst a series of systems
let's just take agitation and stress for
one if an animal or a human is very
thirsty you feel kind of agitated you
might get up and get a drink of water if
you're very thirsty it can put you into
a state of panic if you're extremely
thirsty and water is a limited resource
you might even result to violence to get
it or negotiation of some sort that you
wouldn't if you were calmer so the
stress and agitation we're designed to
actually mobilize the body to take us in
the direction of something that's
adaptive so you can start to see these
kind of core elements of
what the brain and nervous system do
sensation perception feeling thought and
action and this
constant challenge of trying to match
our internal state to the external real
estate the outside world and you start
to see that the sensations that we call
stress or impatience or calm
are really the result of that those
attempts that the nervous system is
trying to perform
that's a lot to take in and super
interesting um and and it
you know it's prompting in me
this um
you know attempt to try to wrap my head
around
what within the brain is mutable which
is kind of you know what your work is
all about versus what is immutable like
you were talking about thoughts like
pop-up windows on a browser
you know some sometimes our brains are
just doing what they do and that there
are things that we can do like
mindfulness and breath work and the
practices that you're talking about
hypnosis which is another thing that
you're you know involved in
to help you know help us like take
better manage better
that process to kind of
take the reins and be more in charge
rather than
be prey or victim to these kind of
things that just occur without our
conscious awareness
well i think that
you know in terms of value of
understanding the nervous system and
where it can be steered it's absolutely
clear that the nervous system can change
in response to experience
so this thing we call neuroplasticity is
really that it's the brain's ability to
modify itself in response to experience
and i think it's important to understand
that from birth till about age 25 the
brain is extremely malleable in a kind
of almost passive way where kids are
exposed to things and the brain is just
wiring up i mean the brain is really
designed to adjust itself
in order to be in concert with its
surroundings and to optimize that just
the way we described them like the way
that a child can learn a language very
quickly or three languages guitar or
something yeah without an accent you
know three languages without an accent
it's remarkable you try and do that
after age 25 it's very challenging and
so
the the brain is basically designed to
be customized in the early part of life
and then to implement those algorithms
and that circuitry for the rest of your
of its life
and so the brain can change in adulthood
and it can change provided that there's
an emphasis on some perceptual event so
in other words if you want to change
your brain as an adult let's say you
want to be less anxious you want to
learn a new language you want to be
more functional in some way presumably
the key thing is to bring focus to some
particular perception of something
that's happening during the learning
process and the reason for that
is that there's a neurochemical system
involving acetylcholine
and it comes from these two little
nuclei down in the base of the brain
called nucleus basalis
all day long you're doing things in a
reflexive way
but when you do something and you think
about it very intensely acetylcholine is
released from basalis at the precise
neurons that were involved in that
behavior and it marks those for change
during sleep or during deep rest later
so for people that want to change their
brain
the power of focus is really the entry
point and the ability to access deep
rest and sleep because most people don't
realize this but neuroplasticity is
triggered by intense focus
but neuroplasticity occurs during deep
sleep and rest and we can talk about
how to optimize those different brain
functions one of the things that's
really important also think about how
the brain works in terms of plasticity
and all this stuff is
what the brain really wants to do is
also pass as much of what it does after
reflexive behavior as possible
so
yeah so when we're talking about focus i
think it can get a little bit vague but
it might be useful to think about like
what exactly is focus and what triggers
plasticity
so the brain loves to be able to just do
things pick up coffee cups and drink and
walk and talk and do things and not put
much energy into it when we decide to
focus what the brain really does is it
switches on a set of circuits that
involve the frontal cortex and nucleus
basalis and some others and it's trying
to understand duration how long
something's going to last path
what's going to happen and outcome what
ultimately is going to happen so
duration path and outcome you know the
the events of early 2020 are a good
example of this one of the reasons why
it's so exhausting to be alive in 2020
is because we are now having to pay
attention to duration path and outcome
how long is this thing going to last
when are
you know when are they going to open up
all businesses did i touch that door
handle does it matter you know right who
are the experts are there any experts
you know there are a lot of questions
whereas normally we can just move
through life without having to do all
that analysis
so
if it's a simple example like trying to
learn a new language or a new motor
skill
or a new way of conceptualizing
something maybe somebody's in a
therapeutic process and they're trying
to work through a trauma or something
like that duration path and outcome
is
built into the networks of the brain we
can do that very easily but it takes
work and it almost has a feeling of
underlying agitation and frustration and
that's because the circuits that turn on
before acetylcholine are of the stress
system so when you or i decide we're
going to learn something and really dig
in
norepinephrine which is adrenaline is
secreted in the brain stem and in the
body and it brings about a state of
alertness
then our attention which is mostly a
diffuse light is brought to a particular
duration path and outcome analysis this
would be thinking about what somebody is
saying what are they really trying to
say a hard passage of reading
a hard you know set of math problems you
know a challenging physical workout
when you do that
these two systems have to work very hard
and the adult brain doesn't really want
to change the algorithms it learned in
childhood but if you do those two things
you have alertness and focus the
acetylcholine and the norepinephrine
converge to mark those synapses for
change
and so
so the way to think about
neuroplasticity if one wants to change
their brain is bring about the most
intense concentration you can to
something
and then later bring about the least
amount of concentration of that thing so
i'll talk about that in a second but
there were some studies that were done
at stanford by a guy named eric knudsen
that showed that plasticity in the in
the adult brain
any age can be as robust as it is in
childhood as fast and as dramatic wow
provided the focus is there and it's all
contingent on this acetylcholine
molecule coming from nucleus basala so
you say well how do you do that how do
you right how do you get it you know
exactly well i've got friends that chew
nicorette thinking that's going to get
them there because nicorette is a
nicotinic acetylcholine agonist but
that's going to globally increase
acetylcholine so i always tell them
that's not the right approach the right
approach is to bring as much focus to a
behavior
or to a thought or to an action pattern
and there has to be a sense of urgency
so what knutson lab showed in another
lab at ucsf mike merzonik's lab showed
is that if there's a serious contingency
like in order to get your ration of food
each day you have to learn this thing
the degree of plasticity is remarkable
right
but if there isn't an incentive it just
isn't going to happen so these circuits
in the brain that mother nature set up
are designed to be anchored to a real
need and people always say to me well
should i do something out of love and a
real desire to learn or should it be out
of fear but either one works the sense
of urgency is just acetylcholine it's
norepinephrine that's all it is it
doesn't the brain doesn't have a
recognition of whether or not something
is pleasurable or not until later once
you start accomplishing your goal the
reward systems like dopamine start
kicking in but
i think if people are interested in
modifying their brain for the better
at least some you know top contour
understanding of how urgency and focus
must converge
for that to happen can be useful because
i think there's a lot of attention paid
to whether or not something feels like
flow or whether or not it's what i call
highly desirable right or whether or not
you can
you can eat a plant out of the ground
that will magically put your brain into
a state of plasticity and the answer is
yes such plants exist
but what's missing is the focus
component if that work is not done with
a particular end goal in mind you'll get
plasticity but you'll get plasticity in
a kind of across the board it's like
learning nine length learning a little
bit of nine languages all at once is not
going to make you
speak coherently in any one of them
so focus is the key right i mean this
idea of flow is so much in the
vernacular now and
you know my my sense is that
people are trying to measure their their
level of engagement against some sort of
theoretical idea of what it's like to be
in that flow state
and if they're not experiencing it they
feel like they're doing it wrong or
they're or they feel guilty or they beat
themselves up
and for me it's a lot of it is just hard
work like right now
i'm trying to finish this book
and i should have been working on this
book for like the last nine months right
and i just couldn't couldn't get it
together like it's a collaborative
project so there's a lot of different
people that are involved in this and
they've been working diligently sort of
daily you know putting this thing
together
and
i've just been focusing on the podcast
and been unable to immerse myself in
this project because i know from past
book projects when i go in i go all in
like the addict in me kicks in and it's
like it just becomes my universe and
i've been completely paralyzed from
taking that on
and so i've dithered away most of the
quarantine without being productive on
this project and then about 10 days ago
we had a meeting and we established this
deadline at you know july 10 to turn
this thing in and it was like a switch
got flicked and i went all in and it's
all i can think about now and in fact
everything else feels like
um extraneous and a distraction i just
want to get back so i can focus on this
thing and
ten days ago i couldn't get myself into
that position and it's made me think
about like what is going on in my brain
that you know it's such a drastic state
change
and what did i do to switch that well a
deadline was imposed upon me and
whatever happened neurochemically with
that set in motion like a chain reaction
of events that got me into the chair and
once i began the project for me it's all
about like momentum right it's it's like
to start getting to the starting line
and beginning is so hard like i will
just go forever without doing it and
then i'm in and then i'm all in 110 and
i'm like why can't i just why can't i be
that person who just worked on it you
know an hour and a half every day for
the last
three months
well i can offer some potential
explanations um i can't relate and none
of it involves a flow state right it's
all hard yeah and you know i'm friends
with stephen kotler i think flow and i
think the cheeks and high who originated
this thing in flow is really interesting
but i i say right now the most we can
say about flow and mechanistically is um
backwards it spells wolf we don't really
understand flow
people have come up with these theories
it's like you know hypo hyper frontality
i i haven't seen the data and i'm not
picking on anybody i'm putting that out
there as a prompt for people to discover
this i think that and to work on it i
think it's a really interesting highly
desirable state but i think we need to
get comfortable
as a as a culture in trying to
understand our species and how we work
that the early stages of hard work and
focus are going to feel like agitation
stress and confusion because that's the
norepinephrine and adrenaline system
kicking in
none of us would expect to walk into the
gym and do our pr lift or
you know perform or go do something
without warming up the brain also needs
to warm up and start to hone in which
circuits are going to be active
and it's it's unreasonable for us to
think oh i've got an hour i'm going to
plop down and write beautifully for an
hour my best work we need to accept that
there's a period of agitation and stress
that accompanies the dropping into these
highly concentrated states now in terms
of the reward that accompanies
the feeling that we're funneling into
that that groove of being productive in
in one regime like for you writing this
book
the dopamine system is really important
to understand so we've talked about
norepinephrine kind of gets you going
acetylcholine is the spotlight of
attention
the dopamine system is mother nature's
hard-wired ancient system in all animals
including humans to put us on the right
path
now it's a lot of people talk about
dopamine as this thing that you get when
you publish the book or when you get the
book deal or
when something wonderful happens like
your child's born and that's true
but dopamine's main role
is to be released any time you achieve a
milestone or you think you're on the
right path and when the dopamine system
is tethered to a particular pattern of
focus remember duration path and outcome
so it's like okay sit down maybe you
don't get much text out but then the
next day you get 800 words of really
solid text and you feel good like i'm
into this what does that dopamine system
do the dopamine system takes the
norepinephrine which is normally rate
limiting like at some point
there's so much norepinephrine that you
quit and we can talk about that it's
actually the substrate for quitting
dopamine can push that noradrenaline
back down that adrenaline back down and
give you more room more space to do
duration path and outcome work highly
focused work and i'm making duration
path outcome synonymous with highly
focused work
why would this happen so let's think
about an animal let's think about a deer
that wakes up
and is thirsty
and it's wandering out looking for water
that animal needs water it doesn't know
that it needs water it experiences
agitation the same way that a baby feels
agitation when it wants food but it
doesn't know it needs food it just
feels agitation and cries and caretaker
comes hopefully that deer is now
foraging for something that it needs and
let's say it smells water because deer
can actually do that and arrives at a
stream and takes a sip of water there's
dopamine released then that puts it on a
path to maybe a larger lake or something
of that sort or to be able to go achieve
food so when we
are on the right path and we hit a
milestone dopamine is released and it
tends to tighten our focus more for that
activity
so the dopamine this is why drugs of
abuse and why alcoholism and
some you know process addictions which
are behavioral addictions are so
dangerous because
they a lot of those drugs of abuse are
dopamine so it becomes this cyclical
loop where there's no other behavior
that can evoke the same level of release
right in fact i sort of define
addiction as a progressive narrowing of
the things that bring you pleasure and i
say that because it really is the way
that the dopamine system works normally
the dopamine system is designed to be
generic it's designed to get me to do
lots of things social quality social
interactions you know work exercise all
those things
just like the stress system is designed
to get me out of bed in the morning a
cortisol pulse is what gets me out of
bed in the morning it's also what leads
me to or led me to pursue a career in
science out of fear initially and
eventually pleasure so
the dopamine system is tethered to those
states of focus
and it's what mother nature designed so
that neural plasticity would occur and
you would want to continue those
behaviors again
in the future that deer needs to know
and remember and create a memory not
just of where that stream is but the
process of oh when i feel that agitation
i'm going to get up and go down this
particular path
and so
people think of the dopamine system as
this kind of like catch-all for reward
oh you get likes on instagram and it
makes you feel good that's not really
how it works
and the important thing to understand is
when you start getting a convergence of
norepinephrine so that level of
agitation duration path outcome
acetylcholine and dopamine
now you're starting to wire in the
behaviors that make people really good
at certain things now in a functional
view of this so not addiction
what this means is that for any of us
success in any endeavor is very closely
related to how much focus we can bring
to that endeavor
and the reward system you start to
realize is entirely internal no one's
coming along and cramming dopamine in
your ear or dripping it in your brain
it's all internal and this starts to
bring us into the kind of like
discussion around mindsets because so my
colleague carol dweck who you know
popularized this growth mindset
it's again a very misunderstood concept
it's the idea that we can change so
that's built into that but the discovery
of growth mindset was of these kids that
actually really enjoyed doing problem
sets that they knew they couldn't get
right but for them they would get this
like dopamine release from just focusing
on the problem they like doing puzzles
they couldn't get right it sounds crazy
but inevitably those kids are very good
at puzzles and very good at math and on
these kinds of things
so growth mindset is i believe a sort of
a neuro neuroscience lens on growth
mindset would be that the agitation and
stress that you feel at the beginning of
something and when you're trying to lean
into it and you can't focus is just a
recognized gait you have to pass that
through that gate to get to the focus
component
and then if you can reward the effort
process you really start to feel joy
and low levels of excitement
in the effort process that's that
buffering of adrenaline that's that
feeling like yes i've got a lot of
adrenaline in my system but i'm on the
right path
it feels good to walk up this hill so to
speak
and when you start to bring those neural
circuits together
you really start to create a whole set
of circuits that are designed to be
exported to any behavior you want
so if it's writing a book great if it's
podcasting great if it's building a
business great if it's if it's
you know building a terrific
relationship great then the circuits
that mother nature has designed are
incredibly generic so that we could
adapt to whatever it is that we need to
do and i think the misunderstanding
around how these circuits work has led
to this idea that there's some secret
entry point maybe marked flow on the
door and there's a trampoline up to that
door and you just open that door and
you're going to be in it right and
nothing could be further from the truth
and anyone who's done well in any career
or athletic pursuit knows this
but unfortunately there's a kind of
obsession with the idea that it's all
supposed to feel good and it does feel
good but there's a whole staircase in
which it feels kind of lousy yeah i mean
the the the ex the the feel-good aspect
of that experience is very subtle and i
think you know in in a kind of global
way what you're talking about is falling
in love with the process like you have
to push this gate open which might
require you know more effort than you're
comfortable with but once you push
through
it is about you know that daily the
daily rigor and the tiny winds that you
get from that
um rather than you know it's easy to you
know you set a goal but that goal
becomes very abstract right and it's
those tiny little things that you're
getting done every day that bring you
that internal satisfaction that are like
calibrating that plasticity is that what
you're saying yeah absolutely and what's
incredible is the extent to which the
mind and thoughts remember earlier we
were talking about how thoughts are
spontaneous you can't control them
negative thoughts traumatic thoughts bad
thoughts trying to suppress those is
futile if there's one message i can send
people it's just don't even work at that
but work at the process of introducing
thoughts as almost like you would
introduce actions because we can
introduce thoughts and you know carol
dweck has talked about this that
positive self-talk is not the same thing
as growth mindset because positive
self-talk is almost always linked to the
ultimate outcome if i'm losing badly in
something and i tell myself i'm doing
great i know that i'm lying there's no
dopamine release from that
and you know a lot of the self-help
wellness culture of the 80s and 90s was
like it's impossible to be in a bad mood
if you're smiling we wouldn't have any
depression on the planet if that's true
there's probably some feedback from the
face to the brain but it's not that
simple
but
the idea that you can self-reward the
effort process is extremely powerful
because what it means is that if you can
recognize agitation stress and confusion
as an entry point to where you
eventually want to go
i do think that just that even just
mental recognition can allow people to
pass through it more easily they think
they're doing something wrong and then
rewarding yourself when you achieve any
milestone like you know running to a
particular location if you're trying to
run a long distance and then registering
that as a partial win
what we know is that the dopamine that's
released in response to that suppresses
the total amount of adrenaline and gives
you more room more time more energy
to run in the running example and this
is anchored in a real scientific result
so last year there was a paper published
that essentially was asking why any
human or animal quits at any behavior
now certain behavior is like i can't
lift a car unless it's a very small car
i can't lift a car but if it's we're
talking about running or we're talking
about
long bouts of work the question is why
do we quit like what is that it turns
out that every time we exert effort a
certain amount of noradrenaline in the
brain is released and there's a sort of
a counter in the brain stem and at some
point enough noradrenaline is released
and it shuts down
cognitive control deliberate control
over the motor circuitry and we quit
that's it but the thing that can restore
those levels or it can sort of reset
those levels lower and give us more gas
more mileage is dopamine and it makes
perfect sense because our species had to
move against very challenging things in
in nature and in in terms of in culture
at every stage of our evolution
including now 2020 is a good example of
this and when a good example would be
if you're really slogging it out and
things are miserable just think like the
worst family vacation everything is a
disaster or a very hard physical event
and someone cracks a joke
you almost immediately feel a sense of
relief
you see this in the team that wins the
super bowl both teams slogged it out you
have to believe they were both at max
effort the entire game look at the team
that wins they have extra energy they're
jumping all over the place so it can't
be physical energy it can't be glycogen
related it's not ketone related it's
nothing in the body in that sense it's
dopamine's ability to take that level of
norepinephrine and smack it back down
and so we can
learn this right i mean i think this is
where there's real power like in your
story
or the story that i'm familiar with
from your book like the the ability to
push through those pain points is
something that we really can export to
other aspects of life because it's the
same neurochemicals that are involved so
when you get to a particular location or
maybe i
recall um you know a portion where
you're just you're feeling lousy you
know you're injured or you feel like
you're hurt and you can reframe it
mentally
and think i'm actually still on the
ladder i'm still holding on to a wrong i
know at least that much i'm still
breathing i know that much and the lift
that we get is not some psychological
pump up it's a neurochemical thing it's
dopamine suppressing norepinephrine and
saying you're on the right path you can
keep going it's a permission to keep
going and we grant that permission to
ourselves no one grants that permission
to us i think one of the other kind of
misconceptions that we want to dissolve
is this idea that
external rewards can actually propel us
down long paths of success and high
performance they can't no it's a
internal sustainable fuel source yeah
yeah i have a friend from the seal teams
and somebody asked us recently we were
given a talk
and somebody said how can i make sure
that i continue to self-reward and i'm
not driven by these um external rewards
how can i continue to have that drive
and uh his answer was very good he said
give away all the external rewards you
know now not all everyone can afford to
do it's just about you and you it's just
you and you and the more attached
there's a famous stanford study done at
bing nursery school probably not far
from where you were in the dormitory
there's a little nursery school in
escondido village and they did this
study where they looked at kids that
liked to um playing during their recess
it's all recess in nursery school but
they're drawing
and they took the kids that really liked
to draw
and they started giving them little gold
stars on their drawings
and then they like the gold stars for a
kid that's an extrinsic reward and then
they stopped doing that and the kids
stopped drawing they just they they
associated the good feeling of doing it
with the external rewards we have to be
very cautious about how much of our
internal dopamine we attach to external
rewards if we want to continue to grow
and pursue and focus and work hard if
you just want to get to some place and
cash in
then fine
but most people find themselves in a
pretty miserable place because their
dopamine was so attached to external
rewards they need more and more of well
the why has to be deeper than that i
mean the thing that that i kind of
always default to when i hit that
breaking point or you know i'm training
or i'm racing or whatever and i'm at
that stage where it's just like i can't
go any further the first thing i do is i
reflect inward on why i'm doing this to
begin with like what is the you know
what is the value system that i'm trying
to tap into what is it that i'm trying
to express like what got me to this
point so it's a reminder
and then i just set like i just say well
i'm just going to get to the next
lamppost or i'm going to you know get to
the the next intersection or whatever it
is i break it down into the tiny i'll
quit after that like the more i can just
root myself in the present moment
and and distill it down into the tiniest
of digestible chunks
that's the only way i can you know
continue to move forward and i've
learned over time that the more i do
that then you know suddenly i'll find
myself in a different mental like it
will shift right just because i feel
that way in that moment is not
determinative of how i'm going to feel
10 minutes later
absolutely there there's an interesting
process that
um that occurs when people start to
realize that rewards are all internal
and what they start to do is they start
linking this duration path outcome thing
to their internal rewards and so to put
this simply one of the most powerful
things that any person can do is to
learn to control
this idea of duration path and outcome
and attach an internal sense of reward
just that you're doing well to reward
yourself mentally just say i'm doing
well i'm actually on the right path
to do that
inside of the
demands that come from the external
world the more often that we can
self-reward some aspect of the process
provided it's in the right direction of
what we're trying to achieve
the more energy we're going to have for
that the more focus we're going to have
for that and remember that the reason i
say energy i don't throw that around
loosely is that
limiting amount of noradrenaline is
constantly being kept at bay you're
literally buffering the quit response
and so when people start realizing that
if they set the goals inside of the
larger goal and self-reward each one of
those they essentially have an infinite
amount of energy to pursue
those goals they have an infinite amount
of focus to pursue those goals you see
this most
in the special operations community and
people that are selected essentially for
this process so one of the things that's
been intriguing to me i have some
friends from the seal teams and i don't
begin to you know really understand the
real work that they do deployed because
i've never done that kind of work but
i've always been intrigued by the
selection process the so-called buds
process right because carrying logs and
getting in cold water and all that
that's not really how
the work is that's really not what the
work is about so the selection process
is interesting because everyone shows up
fit motivated and convinced that they're
not going to quit i mean i think like
there might be a couple to show up to
show up but everybody is absolutely
convinced and then a very small subset
of them make it through
and i'd be willing to bet that the ones
that make it through
of course they're gritty and resilient
but they all are essentially right so
that's necessary but not sufficient
obviously otherwise everyone would make
it through the people that make it
through somehow are able to tap into a
process maybe it's
a reward process maybe it's through
self-punishment maybe it's through
self-reward um in the positive sense but
they're able to control something inside
an environment that is not controlled by
them it's controlled by the by the
instructors and
i've always been struck by the fact that
in order to to
not in order to get through you just
have to not quit remember people aren't
being deselected they're not saying get
out of here you're not good enough
you're not people are deciding that for
themselves
and so it's interesting because
it brings about a real world experiment
of people who are quitting and i believe
they're quitting because they can't
manage these neurotransmitters
and the people when i say manage i think
that the people that get through knowing
some of these people quite well
had an internal process by which they
could reward themselves for doing
something that might have just looked
trivial to everybody else but it gave
them more gas more energy right right
and what's interesting is the process
the kind of unconscious genius of of the
buds process is that
they've picked two sensory events that
are
across the board challenging for
everybody one is cold water which is
great because it most of the time it
can't kill you
right it's not like heat which can kill
you it's cold water and sleep
deprivation
and so the ability to do these like what
i'm calling dpos this uh duration path
and outcome
steps and procedures is great on when
you're rested you know uh you know when
you have a when you have well-fed
well-slept you can do anything you can
be in any hard conversation you can work
through anything so what they do is they
start taking the autonomic nervous
system which is
these deep reserves of the nervous
system that when our autonomic nervous
system is off it starts making us
pay more attention to how we feel than
the demands of the world around us
remember that yeah basic challenge in
the nervous system and so sleep
deprivation
is the best way that you can pull
somebody down from their ability to
analyze duration path and outcome and
reward themselves sleep deprivation is
the way in which you essentially pull
apart the nervous system and the way
that it wants to function because
it's very easy again rested to do all
this but so what they do is they're
sleep deprived people they put them in
cold water they're trying to get them
more in touch with the way that they
feel inside than what they need to do in
response to the external demands right
everyone i know that's made it through
that process did it slightly differently
but i'll tell you how they didn't do it
they didn't do it through sheer grit and
determination they did it through
attaching a sense of meaning they did it
by
micro slicing the day or slicing the day
into a series of meals that they just
need to get to and then rewarding
themselves for getting to that next
milestone so they don't know i mean most
of them
you know probably had very low concept
of dopamine and norepinephrine but
that's the process that's also the
process i think that allows someone to
finish an ultra i've never run an ultra
but i think that process of self-reward
is
grit and resilience in a kind of
neurochemical definition yeah and i
think it's a thing that anybody can tap
into and i think it's therefore i think
it's it's so key because i think people
think that
uh it's just so key that people
understand excuse me that these circuits
are not unique
to people who run ultras or people that
make it through
uh you know stringent filter special
operations command yeah it's the same
thing that it is interesting yeah the
the the the ultimate determinant isn't
your physical conditioning and yet
that's what everybody focuses on it's
what's going on in you know internally
mentally neurochemically that's making
the difference and the people that are
able to best calibrate that and find
these you know strategies for managing
that are the ones that get through
whether it is in ultra or buds and buds
is like this perfect it's almost like
its own lab right for
studying human resilience in a certain
respect but you have actually taken some
of these people and tested them in your
lab including
david goggins right so what what what do
you do when you when these people visit
you and you're like i'm gonna
deconstruct you here figure out what
makes you tick yeah so i um i had the
the good fortune of meeting david at a
consulting event a few years ago and um
i guess i should just say uh david you
probably know this already but he is
every bit as intense as he comes across
yeah i mean what you see on the personal
exactly yeah that's exactly what you see
is what you get um really wonderful and
obviously extremely impressive human
being
um so uh
well david anecdote so the night before
we had this event uh he came out to the
lab my lab we do we study fear we study
courage we study resilience and we say
the underlying neurochemical
substrates for those so we had a bunch
of guys there
a couple team guys um some other folks
and
we bring them in this little room and we
do virtual reality there and one of the
things that we use to scare people um or
to generate a sense of autonomic arousal
is this uh experience of diving with
great white sharks which of course
you're not in water in the laboratory
but it's very immersive and for people
that are afraid of sharks it can be um
quite scary not always but um we also
have heights we have claustrophobia we
got something where you can feel spiders
crawling all over your body if you're an
arachnophobe we you know if you have a
pain point we find it do you spend time
trying to figure out what that pain
point is we do and we do it through some
very covert uh methodology that involves
ai and some fun tools um a bunch of
weird questions that right all right
we're let's just say this from the
moment you step into our laboratory
we're studying you so the um
uh and now i know and yeah exactly so uh
what was fun was you know so i sort of
explained what the platform was and what
we were gonna do and um
and david said uh he goes i don't like
sharks and i i was like all right well
and so then you know this was not a
typical experimental day in the lab so i
just kind of at one point i finished
describing what the tech is and how
we're gonna wire people in and then i
said so um so who wants to go first and
he's like i'll go right of course and
and what was funny to me at that moment
i realized this is interesting because
he he was very explicit about the fact
he didn't like shark scenes very
explicit about the fact that he was
going to be first you know first man in
i mean i it would be inappropriate for
me to describe his data right and we
didn't do a full-blown experiment but
what i can say is he's
whatever it is that david has figured
out how to do it clearly involves taking
whatever adrenaline pulse he feels and
understanding something fundamental to
biology which is that adrenaline
response was designed to move us not to
keep us stationary he uses behavior as
the way to shift
sensation perception feelings and
thoughts he understands how to run that
program in the right direction whereas
most people when they don't like what
they feel they start negotiating
sensation which will never work they
start trying to control their perception
which is hard right they're like i'm not
going to think about that or i'll think
about it differently very hard to
control the mind with the mind he knows
that's a tough one yeah
feelings
lord knows what those are and how to
control them i mean we'll eventually
figure that out as a field but
thoughts are complicated so he just goes
immediately to action
immediately
so when he says just for clarity when he
says i don't like sharks he's basically
saying put me in the shark tank like
he's cueing you to say this is the thing
i'm afraid of and i'm going to be the
first one to volunteer and i know you're
going to put me in the shark tank if i
tell you that right exactly and i think
and i obviously can't speak for him but
uh one of the things i think is very
clear is that he's tapped into this
neuroplasticity process
through the the door through the portal
of agitation and stress he's figured out
and this is really the holy grail of
neuroscience is how can i modify my
brain well you modify it by placing
yourself into discomfort and using that
as a propeller to move you into action
and you know a couple years later when
david was
working on his book and i heard the book
was coming out i think i saw a
pre-release announcement uh i texted him
and i just said look i'm really excited
to see your book
and he said oh that great thank you you
know uh be great if you'd um write
something about like an endorsement i
said oh i'd be honored to i'm happy to
and he said but but i need it tonight
right and this was saturday at i think
it was like 10 30 at night when i texted
him so um it's okay well i'd be happy to
i won't do it now he said i need it by
midnight so i sit down and start writing
this thing and these are short blurbs
but i kind of realized that you know you
want to get it right it's david and you
know my name's next to it and i want to
do do it justice so i'm sitting down i'm
working on this thing and i text him
look i'm gonna be a few minutes late no
problem no problem finally i send him
the thing at like 12 30 at night and
he's like oh bro thank you thank you
thank you i promise i'll send you a copy
this and i was like grateful you know
thank you and then i i realized that um
that time he was living in new york and
i said wait a second where are you he
said new york and i said
it's 3 30 in the morning and he goes
yeah i'm going running
of course and i realized at that point i
was like okay you know there's it's it's
undisputable you know this guy lives the
persona that he
projects into the world
and even that day that consulting gig
you know there was a four o'clock lag
and he was like no let's keep going so
he's figured something out and i think
that his
enormous popularity
is
its urn because he's figured out
that it really doesn't matter if you
come at something from a place of joy
and love and that would be wonderful but
there's a whole other set of ways to
approach this that involve slogging
through the discomfort
the doubts
the wish for things to be different and
starting with behavior
and it's incredible because if you think
about sensation perception feeling
thought and behavior
actually the way to control our nervous
system and feel the way we want to feel
is to run that backwards
behavior thoughts so if you change your
behavior then generally your thoughts
your feelings and your perceptions
change yeah and everyone tries to come
at it from the other end
but he's figured out through whatever
process led him there and incredible
life circumstances how to run it in this
direction of behavior first and i really
think that if neuroscience has anything
to offer
it's
some understanding of what the
underlying chemicals and neural circuits
are
but
the sooner that the human animal the
human species can start to understand
that our our feelings and our thoughts
and our memories and all that is very
complicated but that when behaviors are
very concrete
and they are
the the control panel for the rest of it
i don't want to relegate feelings
feelings are extremely important i don't
want to relegate perception they're
extremely
important but when it comes to wanting
to shift the way that you function to
get better or to perform better or to
show up better or to move away from
things like addictive behaviors
it's
absolutely foolish for any of us me
included to think that we can do that by
changing our thoughts first it's
behavior first
thoughts feelings and perceptions follow
mood follows action mood this is like
been my my mantra forever and you know i
swear by it and
david's example illustrates that that
act first he's developed so much neural
plasticity
that it's reflexive for him to just move
towards the hard thing or the challenge
or the discomfort right
and now the science establishes that
this is indeed the case and yet our
programming our default hardwiring is to
uh you know put us in this place where
we want to ruminate on all this stuff
and wait until we feel like doing
something before we do it or check our
motivations for it but
anytime i'm in a funk or i want to
change my state i have to move forward i
have to do something with my physical
body in order to shake things up and you
know rearrange whatever's going on
mentally so
and it and it works every time it works
every time because the the brain
circuits meaning sets of connections and
chemicals they're there from birth
they're there your whole life and they
were designed for that so in 2018 a
graduate student in my lab published a
paper in nature showing that in the face
of a physical threat
there are three options you can
obviously freeze you can retreat or you
can move forward
and the moving forward response actually
triggers activation of a connection in
the brain to the dopamine circuitry of
the brain and makes it more likely that
you're going to be able to move forward
in the future now what was interesting
to us was that
not only is forward action rewarded at a
neurochemical level which then sets you
up for more forward action but the
highest level of agitation
and stress was associated with moving
forward we always think well if i just
calm myself enough i'll be able to move
forward right but it's the exact
opposite you know and so people who are
paralyzed in fear or that have a hard
time initiating sometimes the key is to
raise the level of stress and agitation
this is why deadlines are so effective
right this is why fear is so effective
this is why that deer gets up out of its
you know nice little den and starts to
move because
it feels a certain level of agitation if
that agitation isn't high enough we will
not move forward and so especially in
the u.s you know we have a culture in
which stress has been created you know
these ideas around stress is that it's
terrible for us when in fact stress is
designed to move us forward towards
these action steps that are rewarded
which then move us forward and so on
so what is the process of of combating
that you know monkey mind that is you
know running whatever narrative
that's keeping you stuck like it's easy
to say like just move you got to take
the action sure a lot of people still
despite
understanding that
intellectualizing that are unable to
you know basically
act as if yeah i think we're dealing
with two
general categories of people who have
problems with motivation and focus and i
think we've failed
to
decide um excuse me i think we've failed
to describe the fact that there are two
groups and not one we think well i need
to calm myself enough to move forward i
think and then other people say well no
you need to kind of ramp yourself up to
move forward here's the way i
conceptualize it based on the data that
i'm aware of
some people
are just hypo aroused they're just not
motivated enough and those people would
benefit greatly from cultivating
practices like super oxygenated
breathing so this is something along the
lines of like tumor type breathing so
rapid and we look at this in the lab
we're actually running a human study on
this now so 25 or 30 deep breaths
through the nose and out through the
mouth
then exhaling the breath and holding
learning to how to self-generate
adrenaline that's what you're doing
some version of the wim hof technique
that's what that is brian mckenzie talks
about right
an ice bath is doing the exact same
thing stimulating adrenaline response it
actually improves the immune system
there's a published paper on this
releases adrenaline which buffers the
immune system against infection
but getting good at taking yourself from
low low energy to higher energy
and then learning how to compress your
focus and i'll talk about the focus
thing in a minute some people are so
agitated the monkey mind they've got too
many things going on and they're
thinking okay they're trying to sit down
and write i suffer from this and i'm
feeling like wait i've also got this
person i need to connect with and i'm
kind of being drawn off course by not
being able to put the blinders on
for people that have that issue i think
learning how to calm the nervous system
is very powerful
and the best way that i know how to do
that is based on two studies one
published in nature one publishing cell
reports recently showing that
physiological size there's actually a
thing in the literature called
physiological size are one of the
fastest ways to bring our overall levels
of autonomic arousal down and a
physiological sigh is a two inhales
followed by an extended exhale so it's
like
it's not just a deep breath it's two
inhales followed by an exhale okay and
what that what that does and this has
been shown
several times now in humans
and other species as well as it dilates
the the little sacs of the lungs and
that second inhale dilates them a little
bit more and it pulls a little bit of
carbon dioxide out of the bloodstream so
that when we exhale we offload the
maximum amount of carbon dioxide and it
perfectly adjusts the ratio of carbon
dioxide and oxygen in the bloodstream
and lungs and sometimes it only takes
one of these double inhale exhales
sometimes somebody needs to do two or
three
but that's the fastest way to bring the
autonomic nervous system down
a lot of people need such a tool because
i think we talk a lot about meditation
and tools for calm and you know i can go
to essline for a weekend and get a
massage i'm going to feel very good but
then when i'm thrown back in real life i
need something that's going to work in
real time what i call a real time tool
and most people don't know how to
control their autonomic nervous system
because it's complicated i can't control
my liver function i can eat that will
calm me but that has complicated you
know issues with it too if i'm just
eating to calm myself
so
the diaphragm
is the one skeletal muscle organ that
was internally right we've got obviously
skeletal muscles designed to move things
it's a skeletal muscle organ unlike the
spleen the liver the heart etc it was
designed to be moved voluntarily and
these physiological size are actually
occurring fairly regularly during sleep
to adjust our levels of carbon dioxide
and oxygen
and there's a recent study showing that
in claustrophobia
this is the breathing pattern that
people default to to try and offload
that carbon dioxide
so whereas there are a lot of really
interesting breathing techniques wim hof
bryan mckenzie does great work uh
patrick mcewen you know the laird and
gabby the tons of people doing really
interesting things out there my lab has
been focused on what are the neural
circuits that are designed to achieve
particular states that happen to impinge
on and capture diaphragm function
and so the reason i think breathing is
so powerful is that everyone has a
diaphragm
and it's the immediate link to the body
a lot's been made of the vagus nerve you
know oh the vagus is the path between
the body and mind but the vagus is very
slow the vagus nerve calming is what you
experience when you eat a really rich a
carbohydrate-rich meal or you're you've
had a long day and you're and you put
your feet up and you're finally relaxing
it takes minutes to hours to kick in
whereas the diaphragm is real-time
control over a brain state so
the brain knows what the body is doing
by how fast the diaphragm is moving it
knows its overall activation state so
when you breathe quickly those 25 or 30
breaths the brain says oh i must be
alert i'm going to start secreting some
noradrenaline and when you breathe
slowly
that level of noradrenaline drops down
so it sounds so simple but i think it's
only in the last two or three years that
my lab and mark krasnow's lab at
stanford and other labs elsewhere in the
world have started to identify the
neurons in the brain that are linked to
breathing and how those two things
relate to one another and i think
everybody should have a kit of tools
that they can use to bring themselves
down and ramp themselves up
i'll just say one other thing about
focus so when we're in a high alert
state something very powerful happens
that i think partially explains your
your ability now to drop into this book
writing
when there's a certain amount of
adrenaline in our system our pupils
dilate remember the eyes are not
connected to the brain our eyes are
actually two pieces of central nervous
system they are two pieces of brain
outside the skull
that were designed to control our
overall arousal state
and so we can talk about this as it
relates to sleep and sleep quality but
when i bring up the level of adrenaline
in my body through breathing or let's
say i see a troubling text or let's just
say i i just use a very goggins type
approach and just
figure out the most painful
inspiring for me reason to do it you
know it's it sounds vague because
obviously david i don't know what goes
on in your head but a tremendous respect
for your ability to do this but he just
ratchets himself out of that ditch and
puts himself in motion
the pupils dilate and when that happens
our visual system actually enters
something that's a little bit more like
portrait mode on our phone
there's a process called accommodation
and your ability to focus on one thing
visually
actually becomes
better and your ability to see
everything else blurs away
and that's the ability to just see that
screen of text or that if you work work
on you know pad and paper to just see
that pad and paper
and then as you start writing what
people don't realize is that mental
focus follows visual focus
and blind people it's slightly different
it follows auditory focus but in
in most people
your visual focus is you bring that
into really sharp relief that image of
your book and you stare you're going to
feel some agitation and your mind's
going to be jumping all over the place
but if you wait just a couple minutes
the rest of the world will disappear i
think this is sort of like the flow
state people are looking for but
remember the gate of entry is one of
which you have to wade through some some
sewage before you can swim in clear
water that's the way i always think
about it but the visual focus
is what brings the rest of the brain
into cognitive focus
and
people in the martial arts understand
this you've probably experienced this
running when you're feeling exhausted
and you can just concentrate on one
milestone and get there you can almost
bring that into like you what you're
doing is you're linking that to the
dopamine circuitry you're saying that
thing is the milestone not winning the
race not some other thing outside this
this immediate environment that thing
and when you're able to start capturing
these peripheral circuits meaning the
body the diaphragm the visual system
then you start getting past this whole
idea of mindsets and it really becomes
about the body setting the mind and this
is where i think when you say action
leads the rest
right it's
that's a what you're saying is a is
grounded in real neurobiological
data there's also a shift in your
perception of time when you're in that
state you know suddenly your
relationship with time
becomes completely different
so i
and i'm not like
you know it's easy to say it slows down
or it speeds up to me it's neither
you're in this weird liminal state where
it's almost like it doesn't exist it's
not it's not a relevant like
vector in your in your emotional
experience
i'm really glad you brought this up
because one of my obsessions is time
perception and you know having spent the
last 20 years or so studying the visual
system what you start to realize is that
space meaning physical space not outer
space but physical space around you and
your time perception
are absolutely linked
and when our focus is very narrow
time starts to feel
thin sliced so so you're right it's not
that it's going fast or slow it's that
you're perceiving more events per unit
time
so it's like a metronome that's going
faster
when our gaze is dilated
so when we're relaxed there's actually a
what happens is the pupil kind of
relaxes a bit it doesn't always get
bigger or smaller but what happens is we
re when we're relaxed so if you view a
horizon for instance or you go into
what's called panoramic vision so even
though i'm looking at you right now i
can dilate my gaze without moving my
head or eyes so i can see the corners of
the room and the ceiling i can see
myself in the environment when we do
that
our perception of time
broadens and we feel like we have more
time and what we're doing when we do
that focus versus defocus as i call it
or focal vision versus panoramic vision
is you're toggling on and off
the autonomic nervous system for
alertness you're turning on and off that
is that norepinephrine circuit and so
it's conscious control over a brain stem
circuit and this is why i don't like the
phrase autonomic because that means
automatic it's a misnomer all the
breathing i can control my autonomic
nervous system i can breathe i can
control my own nervous system i can eat
a big meal i can control my autonomic
nervous system i can focus or defocus
and if you really look at
the realm of high performance what you
start to realize is people who are very
good at their
respective
sport or career or in the special
operations community what they do are
exceptionally good at turning on and off
these systems so they're highly
functional at achieving their milestones
but they're not spending out extra
energy because when you go into
panoramic vision you start to uncouple
this space time thing and you get some
rest and relaxation the way to think
about this is so we go back to duration
path and outcome that's the most
stringent high focus regime for the
brain
the way to get better at duration path
and outcome
is to engage in activities that are low
duration path and outcome where your
brain is not in modes of analyzing
duration path and outcome
what's the one phase of our life when
we're not thinking about duration path
and outcome at all
sleep
and so the reason why
you can pull somebody's mind apart their
ability to think rationally and analyze
duration path and outcome by sleep
depriving them is because sleep
despite all its neurochemical complexity
is really when we restore
our ability to analyze duration path and
outcome now you think about buds and you
go no wonder they sleep deprive them
they're trying to figure out who has the
ability to control these mechanisms and
who doesn't most people fail
so when i think about how to recover
i've i actually don't think about
recovery
as its own thing i think about recovery
as giving buoyancy or improving my
ability to focus
so
sleep
is a turning off of these brain circuits
that are thinking about what's happening
next so some people experience
challenges in falling asleep they need
to learn how to turn off thinking and
there's actually a way to do this we're
doing a study on this now it relates to
hypnosis that would be fun to talk about
and we can if you like the other thing
is that just merely going into panoramic
vision say between a meeting instead of
looking at your phone more focal vision
you're working hard on your book maybe
you walk to the kitchen just two seconds
of what i call deliberate decompression
where you just kind of let your mind go
broader will allow you to reset your
focus much more intensely when you
return to to that book as opposed to if
you look at your phone or engage even in
some other kind of deep duration path
outcome type uh
function of the brain so
when you start thinking about meditation
it's also valuable because a lot of
meditation involves focusing on your
breath i actually think a lot of people
are are spending out
this ability they're they're
working too hard in their the activities
that are designed to reset them so the
two ways to reset yourself in
wakefulness being just very adamant
about my meditation practice that's
right because it's a it's a letting go
it's not right it's you know it's we're
so programmed to like force ourselves to
do things or to like
dive in with intentionality but so much
of this is
more elusive than that
i think that we can
all do ourselves a great service and
performing much better in what we're
doing
by taking little micro recoveries in the
form of dilating our gaze in between
meetings just for a second viewing a
horizon is the best way to do it because
it naturally brings the eyes into
de-focus we're doing this in vr because
we can control the visual environment
completely when you go into this defocus
mode
you turn off that brainstem circuit
you're conserving
norepinephrine for your next bout of
focus and activity otherwise you're
spending it and the brain doesn't care
how you spend it it doesn't care if it's
on instagram doesn't care if it's
watching the news
but learning how to defocus very and
then refocus very quickly can get you
through
a race that you wouldn't otherwise
have been able to get through it saves
you energy and it and it builds energy
the other thing is we talk a lot about
sleep and sleep is extremely important
but there are other modes of and brain
states that can allow you to recover one
of the ones that i'm a
huge proponent of and that my lab has
been studying in other labs or studying
is what many people call yoga nidra
where you i've done yoga nidra a lot
it's a wonderful practice you know just
lying down
and focusing enough of your attention so
that you don't fall asleep and enough of
your attentions on and moving it around
so that you're not really concentrating
on any one thing i fall asleep every
time i do too
i do too but what we know so i
fundamentally disagree with respectfully
though with the idea that we can't
recover sleep that we've lost because
what are we really talking about there
for me it's the ability to perform these
duration path outcome analyses so in my
lab we have people do a cognitive task
and then we place them into these very
deep states of relaxation through things
that are kind of like yoga nidra and
people can find yoga ninja scripts out
there they're everywhere on youtube
elsewhere
or we have them do a hypnosis script
hypnosis is very similar deep relaxation
wandering
sort of attention
fairly narrow context
but it brings the brain into these
unique states where you're neither
asleep nor awake and for people that
have trouble falling asleep or trouble
relaxing themselves these kinds of
practices are extremely useful because
they're really teaching you how to turn
off those modes of focus so you know we
live in a stress society some people are
stressed because they're overwhelmed but
other people are stressed because they
just don't know how to turn off their
brain and fall asleep and so if you want
to learn how to turn off your brain and
fall asleep
these practices are immensely useful how
do you practice hypnosis by yourself
though so there's some scripts i would
recommend people go to one of the
scripts on youtube or
there's some good ones i've never met
him i don't have any relationship to him
but michael seeley s-e-a-l-e-y
australian guy um
has some really good hypnosis scripts
they're just audio programs yeah you
just listen to them and these and he's
not going to make you walk off a cliff
or anything no so stage hypnosis is very
different so i have a very close
collaboration with a guy named david
spiegel who's in our psychiatry
department at stanford we're now looking
at how daily breathing
exercises can impact people's sleep and
levels of stress he's done a lot of work
on addiction and trauma and pain
management through hypnosis and most all
of hypnosis that's clinical involves
bringing one's state into one of deeper
relaxation not full sleep
and then thinking about some behavioral
change that one wants to make these are
ancient practices really and i think
that they were developed by people that
understood
that rewiring of the brain requires
focus
and deep rest what's interesting about
hypnosis is it brings those two things
together at the same moment so normally
you'll work really hard on something
work really hard then you'll sleep and
that's when the plasticity occurs but
hypnosis likely accelerates that whole
process by
having people enter a state of deep
relaxation and focus at the same time
and allows those circuits to reshape
themselves and there's some published
data from david's lab to support that
that's fascinating so i think these
practices are really useful and i think
that if you want to get better at
performing everyone now knows thanks to
matt walker's book and others like sleep
more sleep better but what if you have
trouble sleeping well or falling asleep
well
we want to define what that is some
people have a hard time turning off
their thoughts
it's really hard remember you can't do
it what you can do is to learn to
control that perceptual window and
distribute it so that your sense of time
starts to kind of drift off and you end
up in sleep more easily and it's a
practice that most people find if they
do it for 10 minutes a day or so they
start sleeping much better within within
a week or more you know and sometimes
more they sometimes people need some
other help like not drinking caffeine
late in the day etc but
that brain state of
no duration path and outcome analysis is
going to be the most restorative and you
can get it in wakefulness too so taking
a walk where you're just letting your
mind go
is very powerful and the other thing
that's powerful is optic flow so
self-generated optic flow by walking
running or cycling
shifts the brain into a state of
relaxation that's not seen when you're
stationary this is well dis well
described in the neuroscience literature
for some reason is not well described in
the wellness literature um
but it's a real thing when you move
through space
you're active
you're there's a natural calming of the
brain circuits involved in threat and
threat detection this is the basis for
emdr eye movement desensitization
reprocessing
the lateralized eye movements they have
people do in the clinic that kind of
goofy looking thing while they're ready
to talk about that to overcome fear and
trauma that lowers stress and the the
the rationale is that by coupling a low
stress state
to the recall of the trauma it's going
to allow people to reshape their
relationship to the trauma to tolerate
the discomfort
and it emdr my clinical colleagues tell
me works best for
fairly
well-defined traumas it's not going to
be like my childhood or you know a whole
series of events but for single event
traumas or
a trauma that's repeated but of the same
sort it seems to work best it's not
going to work best to completely reshape
all relationships to all traumas but it
does seem to be powerful for a certain
so basically an example would be if you
got into a car accident and then you're
afraid to get in a car or something like
that right so you take this person and
and you submit them to this therapy
where they move their eyes back and
forth laterally which seems absurd seems
goofy right so this is supposed to help
them get over their their fear or their
blockage yeah so
okay so
my lab studies vision and we study
stress and states of mind and people
used to talk to me about emdr and asked
me about emdr and i was like this is
crazy this sounds like a music genre
this is absurd right or a drug makes no
sense why would moving the eyes from
side to side have any impact on states
of mind that's ridiculous but then what
happened was in 2018 2019 and 2020 five
quality manuscripts came out in very
good journals from groups that were
studying eye movements not studying
stress or trauma that found that these
lateralized eye movements not up and
down but lateralized eye movements
quiet the activity of the of the
amygdala the limbic structure in the
brain that's primarily responsible for
threat detection and stress
and i was like oh my goodness this thing
might actually be real then i started to
dig into the back story of this and
there was a woman named francine shapiro
who came up with this idea actually
walking behind stanford in the stamford
hills she was a therapist and she
figured she had this idea
based on the fact that she didn't feel
as upset about certain things when she
was walking that this might be useful
and she was smart enough to know that
these lateralized eye movements are what
reflexively occur anytime we're in optic
flow we don't realize it because they're
subconsciously generated and they're
very subtle but she realized she
couldn't really take people walking on
their therapy sessions i suppose she
could but it's not really practical it's
raining etc so what she decided to do
was to bring the eye movement component
to the clinic
and have them move their eyes from side
to side while they would recount these
traumas
and people experience tremendous benefit
and in fact now there's a lot of
evidence to show that these lateralized
eye movements really do quiet the stress
of the nervous system and allow people
to continue to move forward this is
probably all anchored i go back to that
story of that deer that needs something
and as it's feeling that agitation and
gets up and starts moving
the movement feeds back onto the brain
to quiet that stress and anxiety so it
can be observant of its environment
and that panoramic mode is what we are
in when we are in a
position to be very situationally aware
when we're stressed we're going to have
you know soda straw view of the world
right on one thing this relates directly
to addiction because i i've spent some
time at addiction treatment clinics and
talking to people in that community
and it's very clear that of course there
are a huge number of factors that play
into why people come become addicted and
relapse etc but if you can get at
people's ability to control their
anxiety
and their feelings of peak states and
happiness
you
you don't guarantee but you
help reinforce the possibility that
they're going to get sober and stay
sober
as an addict gets more tethered to the
idea that some substance is the thing
they need the progressive narrowing of
the things that bring them pleasure and
everything else kind of falls away like
portrait mode on the phone
they're essentially in a state of high
stress trying to meet that dopamine need
all the time and they don't see other
possibilities
the reason i mention not just stress and
treating stress to get out addiction but
also pleasure is that we've also seen
this when do people relapse when they're
feeling really good when they're feeling
really lousy and stressed and when
they're feeling really good they've been
sober for five years we hear about this
in the news usually from you know
celebrity examples people have been
doing great all of a sudden they're back
in treatment like what happened what
happened was the dopamine circuit from
other things maybe a great life event or
things are going well or stress the loss
of a job everything crashing
puts our visual system and the rest of
our brain into a myopia we become we
literally become nearsighted and the
dopamine system says
that's the only thing that's going to
get me out of the mode that i'm in they
literally don't see the other
possibilities so some of the work that
i'm starting to get involved in now is
to try and inform the addiction
treatment community the trauma community
that there are ways to use action in the
body to move people out of states of
myopia nearsightedness and this is kind
of a cognitive nearsightedness
and allow them to start
parsing their
time perception differently it heart you
know it goes right back to time
perception when an addict needs
something
their sense of time is fixed to the
retrieval of that thing or the you know
reaching that thing and then when they
can dilate their sense of time they
realize they have
time for other options but until you can
dilate that
there's really no chance frankly you
can't find a way you can't find a way
you can tell somebody you're going to
lose your kids and they'll do it anyway
and that just tells us we need another
route to it and so one of the things i
think is powerful is to think about how
can we leverage the visual system
how can we leverage the diaphragm system
in the same way that you would tell a
you know somebody who's in you know has
cancer or needs a surgery of a certain
sort like we need to leverage certain
technologies well
we need to leverage certain inborn
technologies of respiration and vision
to be able to access states of mind that
will allow us to make better choices for
the addict in that really nearsighted
view fixated there is no other choice
and i think those early years of
skateboarding and being you know feral
it showed me that these the people i
knew that became addicts and frankly i
know some adults who have become addicts
even who have very quote unquote
functional lives it wasn't
just them
those people
you know we like to think they're making
a bad choice and they had it they're
making a bad decision it's unclear to me
whether or not they have a choice in
those highly myopic states of mind and
so what we need to do is we need to
dilate their perception of the world
around them we need to dilate their
perception of time we need to learn
they need to learn how to relax
themselves so they can actually see
other options and it all relates to how
the visual system and the breathing
system relate to autonomic function
addiction is the
is the perfect sort of laboratory to do
this and it's so important i think
because if it were simply the case that
people just needed family support
and which they do and they needed um you
know encouragement and they need
discouragement about making the wrong
behaviors then this we wouldn't even be
having discussion more complicated
i mean
the thing
i think all of those are are you know
really powerful tools and important
things to look at with respect to the
attic mentality or that disposition
there has to be a level of
self-awareness in that addict that the
decision to pick up the drink or to use
the drug
begins so far in advance of the actual
behavior
by the time they actually pick up that
drink there's no getting in the way of
that like that decision
has so much momentum behind it that it's
almost impossible to reverse so a
breathing technique or any technique at
that juncture is unlikely to be
successful so it's about
recognizing you know when that state is
starting to shift in that direction
whether it's days or hours or weeks
before the behavior choice to intervene
at a position at a place in time when
you can actually have an impact i i
agree i think that
it's always an uphill battle with
addiction at least at first but even you
know just given that the numbers on
relapse you know i think every what was
it that someone once told me um i don't
know if this is actually true but for
most people but he said um a recovered
addict told me you know you know that
every day he tells himself no matter how
dr far i drive i'm always the same
distance from the ditch you know i mean
the addiction community has there's so
many awesome there's so many great
takeaways from it yeah
the what's interesting is
um there's a
a
some verbage around the yogic community
that is very valuable i i can't
recall it off the top of my head but
they talk about the
the great
support that one can get from
learning to access
brain states of timelessness
sleep being very restorative wakeful
deliberate disengagement being very
restorative maybe meditation maybe
through yoga nidra maybe through simple
quick breathing techniques but being
able to dilate and contract one sense of
time and not being locked to one kind of
space-time regime
the ability to to recognize
i'm that i'm not seeing clearly right i
see what i see but i i i don't know what
i don't see the ability to introduce
that understanding for somebody can be
very powerful and i think we need to
give them tools
that they can look to very quickly i
don't think we're ever going to have a
treatment for addiction that's in the
form of a pharmaceutical like one pill
because if you start tapping into the
dopamine system itself you start
degrading other aspects of life so i
think one of the reasons why addiction
treatment is so complicated is that you
need many elements but the elements that
come from the person themselves are
ultimately the most important ones of
course and i think physiology and
neuroscience does have some tools that
can lend support to that yeah
yeah it's interesting i mean i think
that every couple years you see new
science emerge on addiction
and there's some new protocol and you
know 12 steps constantly getting thrown
under the bus and you know 12 steps what
got me sober and i'm very rooted in that
community
uh
i remain open to other you know
modalities and protocols and super
interested in seeing where all of this
is going
but i think it is
important to appreciate how complex it
is like there's a trauma element to it
there's a you know behavioral
modification element to it there's a
emotional like how do you how do you
find a way to anchor this person to a
path a life path that has meaning and
purpose and all of these things inform
this complex you know soup that's going
on in their head that's dictating
whether they're going to pick up a drink
or not yeah and you know and i love the
neuroscience community with you know
it's been my family and home for many
years now and um the people working on
addiction are are
you know motivated from the right place
and they are you know working
exceedingly hard there are a lot of data
now that show you know for instance
there are complete
genetic changes in the cells that can
you know and the pathways that control
dopamine and reward and that's all
wonderful to understand but meanwhile i
think there are enough tools out there
that they need to be aggregated in a way
that's structured and that addiction
treatment communities can can leverage
one of the things that would be of great
use is the idea of a biomarker so you
described that you know and it's it's
really a beautiful example of how when
some early on you might be able to
intervene but later it gets much harder
we need biomarkers that are going to
tell
us for some people or their family that
somebody is at risk the same way you
have biological some kind of woop device
right well i think it's going to come
from
once you know how well somebody is
regulating their own autonomic nervous
system
you can predict pretty well
whether or not they're going to
succeed or fail in making good decisions
and so i do think a woop type device or
other sensor device could be
tremendously beneficial
in
detecting
and telling people whether or not they
are veering off course right and i think
it's getting very minority report though
it is i mean i think machines are going
to help us make a lot of decisions that
we're actually pretty poor at making but
the simplest of those that we might see
in the next two or three years is saying
look you've been working extremely hard
on your book you're doing very well but
you're going to need an extra hour of
sleep i mean that's essentially what
it's doing for you or
in 12 hours you're going to make a bad
decision in 12 hours you're going to
make a bad decision or even cueing or
inter or insert might in there right you
might make a bad decision so that you're
more aware and you're going to devote a
little more mental energy to the kinds
of decisions you're making i think that
as i always i pull a lot of all-nighters
and i still do unfortunately in my
career writing grants and so forth and i
have this rule that i learned my gosh
about 15 years ago which is i don't
trust any of my thinking that occurs
between 3 a.m and 7 a.m if i've been up
all night i just don't trust it because
i start to think the world's falling
apart i start thinking the word the is
misspelled i mean i really know i'm
sleep deprived when words like the look
misspelled and then i'm like yeah what's
going on that's that
duration path outcome circuitry starting
to try to starting to fall apart so i
think that that's an extreme example but
i think that
short of having people buffer their
lives with tons of activities and
perfect nutrition and perfect social
interactions people learning to control
their autonomic nervous system i think
is really the next step in our species
evolution i really believe that what we
are seeing now in the world
is a
a call to arms if you will or a request
from mother nature to
have everybody learn how to control
their autonomic nervous system a little
bit better or ideally a lot better yeah
it's it's absolutely critical i think i
mean right now you know irrespective of
what's going on with the pandemic and
the political climate and the protests
and all the upheaval that we're seeing
as a culture we're experiencing an
extraordinary poverty of attention and
focus
we're so distracted by our devices we're
more anxious and stressed and depressed
than we ever have been before this is
not going in a good direction and to the
extent that we can commandeer a little
bit more control over these things and
understand that we have some level of
agency and we can
reverse this
um sort of automatic
pattern that we're on of just
scrolling endlessly and you know doing
what we're doing that we know is not
leading us in a good direction is
critical if we're going to find our way
forward and to
to speak a little bit to what's going on
right now i think
you know and it's related and i'm
interested in in your thoughts on you
know the the the neuroscience that that
is
you know i think
relevant to this is that we've lost the
ability to
have civil discourse there's a real
breakdown in communication right now
culturally and socially and it's
fractured our society
and it's not it's it's not good right so
what is going on neurologically with
human beings that are attaching
themselves and i so self-identifying
with certain narratives that it's
polarizing
our population and preventing us from
being able to just
be together or united or agree upon what
is true and what is not true and share a
value system so that we can see our way
through the challenges that we're facing
right now which many of which are are an
existential threat to the future of
humanity and the planet
it's a huge problem you articular
articulated it beautifully and i think
neuroscience can offer a couple insights
into why it's happening and perhaps what
we might do about it
so
one of the
scientific results that i'm very
intrigued by is in the 1960s a guy named
robert heath recorded from the human
brain
these are people you couldn't do this
experiment nowadays but skull popped off
my neurosurgery friends tell me that's
no big deal
electrodes lower deep into the brain
all over the brain and people can
stimulate wherever they want and they
just report what they're feeling so
press one lever they feel drunk they
press another lever they feel happy they
press another lever they feel sexually
aroused and they're reporting all this
like
when was this done in the 1960s early
1960s several times actually and
published twice essentially the same
data different populations in the
journal science which is sort of our
super bowl science and nature cell those
are the big ones journals rap that is
so
the number one brain area that people
want to stimulate they finally hit this
lever where they go oh i like that and
they just keep hitting that thing and
hitting that thing and hitting that
thing
frustration and mild anger
i saw that that was a choice i could be
drunk i could be happy i could be i'm
going to choose frustration and anger
exactly it's
what that told us is it's clearly tapped
into the dopamine reward system it feels
like a hit of dopamine to them more than
anything else so we need to
put that on the shelf and keep it
visible as we kind of march into this a
sort of answer to your question
the other thing is an understanding that
and there's some recent data on this
that are really impressive not from my
lab but from another lab which is that
beliefs and information that supports
our prior beliefs
also increases the activity of these
reward systems so the more i see stuff
that verifies what i already think or
feel that they are bad and they are good
or that we are good and they are bad
the more
dopamine and adrenaline is released into
my system which we now know from our
discussion a few minutes ago
changes the way i view the world it
actually changes the way i view the
world it means that i'm going to see
certain things and not see others and
this also relates to the auditory system
i'm going to hear certain things and not
hear others the things that verify my
beliefs are i'm going to feel rewarded
for the things that are counter to my
beliefs i'm not going to be as rewarded
for so we have all these barricades to
empathy and to really listening and to
really hearing what the other side is
trying to say and we have all these
support networks in our body and our
brain which are building a bigger and
bigger divide
and that's all very depressing so the
question is what's the boat that's going
to get us across that divide
and i believe
and i i'm not just defaulting to this
because it's what my lab works on but i
fundamentally believe
that the boat that's going to get us to
the other side
is
our ability to control our internal
state to be able to ratchet down our
level of autonomic arousal just enough
so that i can dilate not just my vision
of what's happening in my immediate
environment but i can dilate my
cognition my thinking to the possibility
that there may be a kernel of value in
what somebody else is saying even if
it's about me and i don't like what i'm
hearing now for as somebody who spent
time in the addiction treatment
community you you probably know this is
a lot of what you get good at as you
learn to move through
something that to you feels very good
and you know all the reasons why it
would probably be good to change it but
you know what you don't want to
because it feels so good so we're
talking about an addiction to entrenched
thinking we're talking about an
addiction in neurochemical systems that
support
lack of change my refusal to change and
stubbornness
and i actually think just like in for
the treatment of addiction and trauma
the key is to get people to learn to
tolerate progressively higher levels of
stress and maintain
dilation of
sensory experience of thought experience
we've got to create some small
little
portals through which information can
come in a lot's been made of mirror
neurons i hate to break it to the crowd
but the data in support of mirror
neurons in humans is not that impressive
and now the mirror neuron people are
going to come after me but fine
there are circuits in the brain
that control emotional contagion
and those are what's powerful
my ability to recruit you into stress
is much more powerful than my ability to
recruit you into empathy for something
good that's a well-established
neurobiological fact or empathy for for
for someone's perspective that i'm
you know that i'm fundamentally going to
disagree with right so i think there are
three gates to getting there and by
there i think we're you know i'm
referring vaguely to the idea that
we need to increase our level of
understanding at least our level of
discourse so that we can hear other
really hear other people's ideas even
though we don't like the way it feels
and we love the way that we feel this is
what that result said we love the way we
feel we don't like the way other people
feel the first thing
is to bring the level of urgency that we
feel internally down we need to learn to
calm ourselves in order to really have
the information start to come in
now the system right now and people out
there everyone's in a frenzy and you can
see it our collect the collective
consciences is kind of losing its mind
it's kind of out of its mind we need to
learn how to turn off those amygdala
circuits so are we all going to get
together and do emdr probably not
are we all going to get together and do
breathing exercises probably not not at
scale
what we need to do is start to figure
out
how we can i think especially for the
next generation of kids how to teach
them to regulate their nervous system so
that they recognize that pulse of
adrenaline as placing them in a
compromised position
like we have to leverage the idea that
being able to hear and listen hinges on
the ability to be calm
so therefore the ability to be calm
is crucial to hearing and listening and
hearing and listening is crucial to our
advancement as individuals and as groups
the problem is everyone's been trying to
do this backwards they've said we all
have to get along we have to cancel
cancel culture we all have to
you know listen to one another and i
think again we have to start from the
inside we have to teach it
physiologically
now i don't have a master plan on how to
do that but one of the reasons i'm here
and one of the reasons i'm you know
teaching neuroscience on instagram and
not just in my laboratory is until we
can learn to regulate the self
i don't think we're going to get where
we want to go as a culture i think it
really does start with our in own
individual ability to to do that and so
you know david's a really good example
for instance of somebody who learned how
to deal with his own internal mess and
build something beautiful out of that
and he continues to do that
and everyone's got to find that process
for themselves and whether or not you
have a perfect family or whether or not
you consider yourself the most inclusive
and accepting person in the world or not
everyone needs to learn how to do that
for themselves and everyone thinks we do
it pretty well
but i think it's clear that none of us
do it well enough so autonomic arousal
autonomic arousal autonomic control i
think those are the entry points for
addiction for trauma
and for really empathic hearing and
listening and until we do that i think
our species is going to continue to go
around this merry-go-round yeah where
every 50 or 100 years we crash right up
against the same general set of issues
only now social media has made it
slightly more a lot more complicated
it's it's a little bit similar to what
you were talking about
in terms of
the
seeking external validation versus
finding it within yourself like
essentially the protocol the
prescription that you just gave
has a strain of buddhism in it in the
sense that
the world's gonna change when we change
ourselves like the best most impactful
way that you can make a difference for
the world is to focus on being the best
version of yourself how can you comport
yourself in a way
that allows you to be more receptive and
objective and empathetic and able to
listen and hear
and
um and i think that's true it's 100 true
and then i think about the person losing
their [ __ ] and you know target or
whatever over the masks or whatever ins
you know insane video clip of the day i
happen to see on social media and i
think
we're doomed like is this person going
to do that no i can't control that i can
only control
myself
and i worry that when
the onus is on the individual to solve
the problem
that um
that we're not going to find our way
through it right like we obviously need
organizational institutional and
systemic changes we need to change the
way these social media platforms work
the way in which we're delivered
information and the way in which we're
siloed
but
i don't have any control over any of
those things the only thing i have
control over is
my own internal mechanism
so what other choice do we have well i
think we need people in positions of
power and leadership who are very good
at internal control
you know i i think emotions are great i
experience them often intensely
but uh congratulations thank you um
they're not always wonderful to
experience but
i think it's clear that the level of
autonomic arousal that's associated with
emotions either very high or very low
very happy or very sad very anxious or
very angry
clouds are judgment it's very clear and
i think the sooner you give them too
much credence too they're just feelings
man like we don't have to allow them to
overtake us and monopolize everything
that we do they were designed to push us
along certain behavioral paths
but they
they've grown in importance
in the last few years and
you know we could get into a discussion
about how you know social media
marketing are designed to you know
capture these very deep limbic aspects
of ourselves and they are
but what's amazing is and important is
that everybody has a forebrain uh some
people it seems it's more developed than
others but everybody has one and we have
this capacity for what we call top down
control which is the ability to
intervene in our own feeling states and
our own action states and to set some
some rigor and some
some real clear marks that we're out to
achieve and i think it's going to start
with the the generation that's very
plastic right now yeah you know most
parents
are afraid of stressing their kids
because they don't want to you know
again i went to a high school where kids
literally at gun high school in the last
10 years kids have you know they've been
over a dozen you know train track
suicides
so
those are kids that are committing
suicide for different reasons but a lot
of them is because they just feel too
much pressure so obviously we can't you
know we can't pressure kids beyond their
capacity to
regulate but
the idea that all of our internal state
should be driven by external things
that's that's a foolish misstep also so
i think we need to
operationalize what we're going to teach
the next generation you know maybe our
generation isn't really rescuable
but maybe the next generation is and if
they understand that
there's some concepts that sound a
little mushy
like gratitude
or mindfulness or these kinds of things
but as long as they understand that for
instance gratitude which we didn't
really touch on
involves a whole other neurotransmitter
reward system in the brain the serotonin
system which buffers us against injury
it can improve wound repair it can allow
us to lean back into these high stress
regimes
learning and you know kids learning how
to toggle their nervous system back and
forth between highly
you know duration path outcome focused
states of trying to improve and learn
and then learning how to really relax
and chill out and enjoy and be socially
connected because it will allow them to
ratchet back in and focus with extreme
depth i think in doing that we might not
get every child to learn how to do that
but if we can distribute that
information widely enough
and there's so many brilliant examples
and beautiful examples yours david's
many others of people that have been
able to tap into those systems
intuitively if we can get that
information out there
i really believe that at least a subset
of those kids
will
grow up to be the leaders that our
species really needs in order to get
through this next filter and right now
we're feeling the stringency of that
filter and i think our level of
autonomic dysregulation as a as a
species the fact that we're there we're
here right now
says okay here's the here's the task are
you guys going to figure yourselves out
you got this forebrain my dog doesn't
have the forebrain i've got he can't
figure it out but we can work this out
and it'll involve technologies like
devices to measure how we're doing maybe
some machines to guide that that's a
different discussion but i think it's
entirely possible and i think that's the
evolutionary pressure that we're in
right now
and i think that the next generation if
they can hear about it and learn about
it is going to meet that demand our
species has done it for every other
demand i toggle back and forth between
extreme optimism and and you know
dystopian despair because
on the one hand
you know you described the the
experience of going to therapy and you
know how that was kind of you know novel
at that time but
we're not in that place anymore and
everybody's got a smartphone and there's
you know headspace and calm and waking
up and all these incredible apps and
mindfulness is part of the mainstream
modern vernacular like these kids are
growing up
not only aware of
these practices but amenable and you
know they're they're it's it's being
done in the households in which they're
being raised which i find to be you know
that's an amazing thing i think there is
a consciousness you know that is
emerging out of these young people that
hopefully
you know we can rely on to solve some of
these problems
and then you know i just think about the
endless scrolling and the social you
know i'm just like oh yes
we're [ __ ] well i think it's clear
that most people young or old are
content to be passive consumers and
spend out their dopamine doing
essentially meaningless activities and
consuming food and consuming
air and light that is basically damaging
to themselves and they i don't think
they care
i i think they're our species let's be
fair our species is
non-essential well no no i didn't say
that our species although sometimes i
think it'd be interesting if some other
species ran the earth but we're the
curators of the planet so i think that
our species
is probably divided into those that are
really going to try and maximize on this
gift of neural plasticity right we're
the only species that has
neuroplasticity throughout the life span
and that
neuroplasticity in childhood lasts as
long as it does as a function of our
total lifespan it's incredible so we
were gifted this and i think some people
leverage it and take advantage of it and
other people don't and i think we need
to accept that we're not going to get
everybody
but what we need to do is attach the
reward systems of society financial
socioeconomic etc to the kinds of
behaviors that are going
is gonna give rise to people that can
lead us into the next hundred years and
200 years now that is not saying oh do
away with monetary systems or actually
the opposite i think that once people
start to realize that your high
performing
military elite military your high
performing athlete your high performing
academics your high performing business
people they actually have practices that
they use to regulate themselves to in
order to not just perform better but
sleep better and not just to sleep
better but to listen better not just
listen better but incorporate ideas that
allow them into states of of creativity
and states of mind that really lead to
new and exciting ways that humans can
interact and the many people will just
be consumers of everything they produce
well all of the what's what's great
about
new media is that
we've we've democratized access to this
information and we're able to realize
that
that these people are not just freaks of
nature but that they have a methodology
and they've created this canon this
toolkit and
these practices are available to
everybody and you have people like david
who are explaining this in very plain
terms that it is within your power to
take advantage of these things to take
better control of your life and we've
never seen anything like that before in
the history of humanity and i think that
that you know that bodes well for the
empowerment of the next generation as
well i do too i as you can probably tell
i'm i'm optimistic yeah i have to be uh
because otherwise i can't justify the
work that we're doing
uh but i think that
there's so much interest now in
psychology and the brain and the self in
physical fitness which you know i think
it's fair to say is
inextricably linked to mental fitness
and the fact that
people are so curious about what other
people are doing and what are the paths
to success and you know what are the
resources for trauma and addiction i
think there's been a kind of swarm of
information it's been hard to sort
through
but i think
2020 is our um
you know as our sort of call i keep
trying to call
because i guess i i do feel that way
it's very serious this is this is
serious business and this is the time
for
us and the next generation to step up
and
you know and to lead people toward a
place where they we can function better
and where the next generation will
reflexively function better that's that
beauty of early childhood is that if
some of this stuff is taught and passed
off it's not going to be perfect but
there will be a generation of people
coming up that will
naturally understand stress and
agitation as taking them off their game
and leading to bad decisions will it
make the appropriate adjustments and
there are people that will that read
david's book in your book and will see
the possibility of doing something
differently with it with a terrible
childhood or a brutal addiction
and
you know i think we we need more stories
of success i think it's easy to look out
there and see all the things that are
going wrong and we need to keep paying
attention to those but we need these
beacons that draw people forward and i
say that from a place of experience i
mean i used to have to find it in books
in the bookshelf i there was no online
back then or in mentors and you know you
have to forage you know i think kids
they have to have that foraging capacity
they can't just sit there and wait for
it to rain on them or for a parent to
dump it on them but i trust that they're
out there and that they're gonna figure
it out just like you're doing on
instagram you're dropping these videos
basically every day right like more
little little lessons on neuroscience
i'm trying i'm trying to show people
that um i have a kind of no acronym rule
so i don't like embedding things in a
lot of complex language sometimes i have
to use an acronym but yeah teach people
a little bit about how their brain works
how it interfaces with psychology
everyone's got different goals and and
purposes in the world but um you know
that scientists are
normal people and that hopefully science
has something i think really science has
something to offer but it's not going to
happen if i'm vaulted in my lab where my
papers are read by the 12 people that
care enough to read the paper start to
finish
so
i'm i'm doing it um there are others out
there of course david sinclair is doing
it sachin panda is doing it i'm trying
to recruit more people from the
scientific community to do this i think
it's our responsibility
you paid for it it's your tax dollars
you know there's a tremendous cost to
doing science that is not often
discussed but i don't really consider it
an option i consider it my obligation
and i'm going to keep going well keep
doing it man i appreciate the work that
you're doing i think it's really
important work we need it now more than
ever and uh it's cool that you're
getting out there and and sharing your
wisdom with everybody it's super
empowering so thanks man appreciate
digging on andrew best way to uh find
him is
instagram he wrote
lab cool yeah all right man coming back
i i made all these notes all the stuff i
wanted to talk to you about we got
through like ten percent of it so
i tend to run live
yeah i just i just was getting out of
the way man to
to you know listen to what you have to
say i appreciate it thanks man thank you
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you